nicolas sarkozy qui se dit prêt à voter
pour françois hollande face à marine le
pen en cas de duel c'est une bonne chose
selon vous remords tardifs remords parce
que c'est la première fois qu'il dit ça
il a été beaucoup plus ambigu dans
beaucoup de ces déclarations avant
tardif parce que j'y vois une tentative
un peu désespérée essayer de récupérer
dans son camp des électeurs qui lui
reprochent justement d'être beaucoup
trop près du front national politique de
recentrage ça suffira pas mais en tout
cas c'est en effet la volonté
probablement de donner à une partie de
son électorat plus centriste dégage
qu'il n'a pas donnés jusqu'à une bonne
stratégie vous pensez non moi je pense
que dans la vie politique faudra des
boussoles claire lisible et s'y tenir